what up
you racist bigoted nazis
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for today july
7 20 21
click that subscribe button would you
tap that notification
bell share our videos etc
etc you'll feel good and you'll be doing
me a favor
all right we got three stories for you
today and i'm excited about all three
we're mixing it up a little bit today
uh so we're gonna get to it pretty
quickly the first story espn now you may
remember espn it was a sports channel
uh actually the reason that i do this
the reason that i am a guy
that talks to the camera is because when
i was in
high school and then really in college i
would watch
espn sportscenter and that's what i
wanted to be it was when craig kilbourne
you may remember him he was the original
host of the daily show he was on
the big show as they called it and keith
olbermann before he became a complete
leftist whack job nut job lunatic he
co-hosted sportscenter with dan patrick
and it was this great show that was
funny and about sports and irreverent
and cultural and really wonderful
and then just in the last you know 20 25
years
espn has been completely infected by
wokism it's mostly about politics now
i don't watch espn anymore i don't watch
the nba anymore i really don't watch any
professional sports anymore as you know
i
do cardio to old nba games from the uh
from the early 1990s actually this
morning i did an hour
to game seven of the western conference
semifinals 1995
rockets versus uh sons mario ellie's big
big three at the end i'm sure you guys
all remember that one anyway espn
is really horrible and it's become all
about politics and wokism and everything
else and there's a reporter
at espn by the name of rachel nichols
who i remember from years ago a
perfectly fine reporter
and she basically got caught on
leaked audio from a year ago saying that
her career was sort of in a little bit
of trouble there because
uh she's white and that there was a
black female reporter that they wanted
to boost up to make it look like they
were doing more related to diversity
so she actually told the truth right
because they're all about diversity and
inclusion
and you're not going to believe this she
then got demoted for it it's such a
perfect story of why wokism destroys
everything so we're going to talk about
that
uh then gensake not pasaki but jensaki
i'm trying to trying to be good today
she gave another white house press
conference and this woman who is just an
abject uh destroyer of truth
well now she's basically laying the
groundwork for the biden administration
to promote further lockdown so we'll
show you some video on that
and then the third story that we're
covering today only three for you today
is that donald trump just this morning
has announced a class
action lawsuit now class action that
means a whole bunch of us can get
involved too
but he's going to be the lead actor in
the class action lawsuit against the big
tech companies
and against some of the ceos of the big
tech companies personally
so this is this is a serious escalation
seriously
interesting and we shall see what
happens so that's what we're doing today
before i get to any of that though guys
is this 24-hour news cycle
making you nauseous i know it's making
me nauseous are you feeling
nauseous on your commute right now all
those trained subways and
bumper-to-bumper traffic
are they making you sick to your stomach
we've all experienced that horrible
feeling whether it's in the back seat of
a car staring at your phone maybe
after one too many uh on a night out
with friends or even just from the
anxiety of a long work day
nausea can ruin a day force us to change
our plans and in the most severe cases
it can make it on a make you unable to
function
for those of you who can relate i've got
good news for you you got to check out
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared
anti-nausea wrist band that's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the products 100
percent drug free non-drowsy and
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as needed
how it works is relief band stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that controls
nausea then it blocks the signal your
brain is sending to your stomach telling
you that you're sick
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve
nausea for patients but now through
relief band
it's available to the masses anyone who
deals with nausea knows how awful it is
even if you don't get nauseous often
relief band is worth trying for the
anxiety benefits alone
this is not a product that you want to
miss out on it'll bring you peace of
mind and help you not worry about nausea
again
as the world is opening back up don't
let the fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines
and if you're getting ready to take that
summer road trip hopping on a boat or
you're just
anxious about heading back into the
office i've got good
good news right now relief band has an
exclusive offer just for my audience
if you go to reliefman.com and use promo
code ruben you'll receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee that's
r
e l i e f b a nd dot com and use promo
code ruben for 20
off plus free shipping and now back to
me and just on a personal note
you may want to use relief band if
you're ever watching cnn or msnbc it's
it's the surefire way not to puke your
brains out as you listen to
uh chris cuomo or rachel maddow
okay speaking of rachel's let's talk
about
espn's rachel nichols this story has
been breaking over the last couple days
and i just think it's it's such
a perfect example of how not only does
wokism destroy institutions
it takes out good people who have done
nothing wrong so rachel nichols
is a perfectly fine reporter mostly does
nba stuff for espn
you guys all know about how infected
espn has become
and as i said in the lead-in it's gone
from what was
a great show about sports that was
irreverent and funny and
silly and culturally relevant to just
endless politics and everyone's racist
and you know america's bad all the stuff
you guys get it
well back last july so basically a year
ago
rachel nichols was caught on audio that
we're going to play for you
in just a second but it wasn't leaked
until the last couple days now the nba
finals is i guess happening right now
i'm not watching so i'm not totally sure
what game they're in or if it's over or
what's going on exactly
i believe it's the bucks and the suns if
i'm not mistaken um
but the audio was held basically for a
year
to give you a little more backstory
we've got some quotes here from the new
york post
espn has removed rachel nichols from the
sidelines for the nba finals the network
announced on tuesday
the move was made in the wake of a new
york times report about
demeaning comments that nichols made
around a year ago about work about
network host maria taylor during a
private conversation
nicholls did not realize that the video
was being recorded the video was then
disseminated by an
espn employee in the tape conversation
from last july nichols said that espn
might have her relinquish her
contractually
agreed upon mba finals hosting job to
taylor
because the network was feeling pressure
to be
more diverse okay so first off i just
want to clarify something i'm reading
right there from a new york post article
what you're going to hear
rachel nichols say there's nothing
demeaning in it so the new york post
actually did not do great analysis there
which is why i wanted to read the
read the quote because the new york post
which is actually usually pretty good
you're going to see there's nothing
demeaning that nichols is saying about
her colleague
she's actually saying the truth which is
that she's going i'm white
this girl's black they've got a
diversity problem it's their problem so
i could be in trouble
now take a listen to the audio they said
to me
hey instead of posting in their nba
formula
reporter
because yeah
i don't know what their next move is but
they are feeling pressured because of
all of that and um
i'm trying to figure out like how to
just you know nothing wasn't i think i
was going to take her all the success in
the world
she covered football she's every
basketball if you need
to hear from more things to do because
you're feeling pressure about your other
crappy long-time
record adversity which by the way i
myself like know personally from the
female side of it like go for it just
you know find it somewhere else
tell me this is not the most perfect
like
chef's kiss example of why wokism
destroys everything rachel nichols
didn't say anything offensive there as a
matter of fact
she said that she wishes maria taylor
all the success in the world she thinks
she's a decent reporter who covers
football and basketball and everything
else and
that she rachel nichols as a woman
has had to deal with discrimination at
espn
but she's saying they're feeling
pressure
they espn by allowing this woke nonsense
and what she's saying is me
i do a decent job as a reporter i've
been at espn for she's probably been
there for
15 years or so can we find out how many
years she's been there exactly she's
probably
it's probably about 15 years or so she's
saying i could be in trouble because i'm
a white woman
and in essence they are the ones that
want diversity and inclusion everywhere
so they basically want me to step aside
so that she can rise well this is my
career
and she's not guilty of anything she's
guilty of nothing so let's just be clear
she wasn't being a racist she wasn't
being a bigot she was telling the truth
and she was applauding the person who
now is in essence going to replace her
because of the nonsense she's been with
them since 1995.
so actually the year that i from the
basketball game that i just watched this
morning
she's been with espn since then anyway
the reason this story is so perfect
is okay you take a sport everyone wants
to watch sports because of sports then
you infect woke-ism now everything's
about racism all the time
then you have decent reporters like
rachel nichols who in this case is
telling the truth
they're the ones that get punished for
telling the truth she did not say
anything
racist there anyway rachel nichols then
issued some like sort of half-assed
apology
and it's like man if anyone that plays
with this thing this is the
you want a bumper sticker for this
segment guys anyone that plays with
woke-ism
will be destroyed by woke-ism every
institution that lets it in will be
destroyed by it and every person
that that plays with it knowing that
it's wrong what rachel nichols is saying
it there
in that audio that by the way was leaked
a year later so why did it get leaked a
year later like what espn employee was
sitting on it for a year were they just
waiting
for the nba finals to in essence take
her out is this a friend
of maria taylor like i don't know um
so but the point is if you let it in an
institution it's going to take down the
institution which is why espn's ratings
are tank
tanking the nba's ratings are tanking
the nfl's ratings are tanking you know
which sport isn't doesn't have tanking
ratings the nhl
where they're still proud to sing the
national anthem and people don't kneel
and everything else
but not only will it take down the
institutions it will take down good
people like rachel nichols this is just
a girl who likes basketball
who likes to report on basketball and
share her opinions and everything else i
have a healthy respect for people that
talk to the camera that share their
opinions openly
she said the truth a year ago and now
she's being demoted so congratulations
espn you're destroying your organization
and you're destroying good people
all in the name of social justice it's
just
spectacular guys before we move on to
story number two
uh as you know once a year i like to go
off the grid for the month of august we
actually just booked our trip to an
undisclosed location
after spending the last year cooped up
at home i'm excited to be traveling
again and looking forward to a real
summer vacation
whether it's for work or play a lot of
us are on the move again this summer so
my advice to you is take your ray cons
with you
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes or powering yourself
through a workout with a pumped up
playlist a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference you're going to get
crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium audio brands
raycon look great and feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors and
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable in-ear fit
and recons are built to go wherever you
go with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing
and a compact charging case i use them
when i'm walking the dog listen up
raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get
them
go to buy recon dot com slash ruben
there you'll get 15
off your entire rakon order and it's
such a good deal you'll want to grab a
pair and a spare
that's 15 percent off at buyracon.com
reuben by raycon r-a-y-c-o-n.com
reuben and now back to me all right
let's talk about
jen saki i know you guys like it when i
when i talk sake when we do clips about
saki they go bananas because people
cannot believe this woman
this woman lies and lies and lies and
lies and lies
she knows she's lying we know she's
lying she knows we know she's lying and
she continues to lie
that's what liars do and we're
surrounded by a lot of them these days
well now she's sort of already laying
the groundwork
for the federal government the biden
administration to endorse
states doing more lockdowns and i
guarantee you it's coming guys
quote me on this on july 7th
2021 dave rubin says more lockdowns are
coming of course they're coming
because the last year and a half was a
test how quickly
would we all fold and basically we
folded quicker than a wet paper bag
we just all went down and you know we we
all have blame on us right if
trying to figure out who to blame just
look in a mirror and i would include
myself in that
we should have fought harder from day
one you know we all we all did the two
weeks to flatten the curve thing
and then they just ran with it and ran
with it and any and on the top of the
fact that we now know
that lockdowns just didn't work they
they work to destroy the economy and
wreck lives and cause depression and
alcoholism
and a whole bunch of other problems but
they did nothing in effect
to stop kovid well here's sake talking
about how biden would
certainly support states uh locking down
once again
if the number of cases continues to
trend upward are there any circumstances
under which
the white house would reimpose some of
those restrictions
um as cases tick up or would that be up
to the states
well states are going to have to make
evaluations and local communities are
going to have to make evaluations about
what's in their interests and as you
know there are
much higher rates of vaccinations in
some parts of the country over others
and we certainly support
their decisions to implement any
measures that they think will help their
community safe
okay so on one hand i'll try to give
credit where it's due the answer there
the last basically
the last sentence that she says there
where she's gonna say we're gonna let
the communities do their thing
you guys know i'm a states rights guy
right like so i want local communities i
want states to make decisions
for themselves so a guy like desantis
can do the right thing in florida
and a guy like newsome can do the wrong
thing in california to me that's a
better option than saying that the
federal government should tell
everybody what to do so i will give her
credit there
on that but that's not really what's
going on here and i would also argue
that the question i don't know who it
was that asked the question but it seems
like a very leading almost like a
planted question
to lay the groundwork for future
lockdowns like nobody's talking about
lockdowns right now
is anyone in your world anyone that you
know that you're married to that you
live with that you hang out with that
you had dinner with that you go bowling
with
is anyone being like oh we're gonna need
more lockdowns or is there
is there anyone out there really that
even the people that are
triple masking still and they've had 18
shots and everything else
going oh if if it gets worse we're going
to need lockdowns again
so the idea that someone at a press
conference is sort of tipping to them
like
is there any way that you'd kind of
support lockdowns in the future like is
that something you do
it just seems like a very odd question
to ask but anyway i'll give sake credit
on the second half of it which is
you know you leave it to the local
communities the bigger
issue though is that we know lockdowns
don't
work so why say that like you could say
yes
if there was evidence that lockdowns
work we would leave it to the states
because we don't want to use the power
of the government
the federal government to do everything
for everyone at all times and as i've
been saying for a year and a half if you
live in
rural montana the regulations
and the way that covid might spread is
going to be very different
than it would be say in metropolitan new
york city
but there's no evidence that they work
so why would we ever tolerate this
and that's why so much of this had very
little to do
with a virus with over a 99
recovery rate and a virus that basically
everyone who died had a comorbidity
and had either cancer or heart disease
or diabetes and that's not to diminish
any of the people
that died and we all know people that
had coveted and i know
actually many people in my family had
coveted and everyone survived and i have
many friends
that had coveted and everyone survived i
actually i'm not even sure
about my own antibody test but i was
sick a few weeks ago maybe i had covered
i don't know here we are
i'm okay life goes on but the idea that
we would
ever that any of us regardless of
whether you live in florida or new york
or anywhere else
that we would ever give the power back
to these authoritarian lunatics
to keep us out of work to keep us away
from our family to stop us from going to
funerals i mean the litany of horrible
things that they did while gavin newsom
spent 20k on a bar bill at french
laundry and while gretchen whitmer who
told people
she didn't want them to be gardening
outdoors in their own house in michigan
while she was getting on a yacht and
lori lightfoot was out there protesting
in chicago without a mask while locking
down her state and i could go
on and on and andrew cuomo sending the
old people back into the old age homes
where they all died and what's happened
with that is he going to jail like
what's going on here
the point is it's not whether the states
should have the power the federal
government should have the power i think
you know what i feel about that
the point is this [ __ ] does not work
not only does it not work we know that
once you give these people the power
to shut down businesses to say you have
to be at home by 10 o'clock because
covet doesn't spread
from 10 pm to 6 a.m or the rest of the
nonsense they will gladly
keep taking the power so as i said
before we all kind of failed the test
and if we don't want to fail the second
test
the second test will be hey if we do it
to you all over again
deja vu all over again are you guys all
gonna fold and bow immediately
i suspect most people still will for
somebody there's something about the
human condition or it's something about
a dysfunction of the modern
the modern human in 2021 that apparently
we like to be controlled we like to be
told what to do
we like the idea that there's some
structure above us that can tell us how
to live i think this probably has to do
with a largely secular society on
steroids and a complete lack of belief
in anything other
than government and a whole bunch of
other stuff that i will continue to talk
about and find the
philosophers and the religious leaders
and the sane
secularists and liberals whoever is left
to talk about these things
and uh i don't we just gotta we got a
big problem here because
when you take all of what the government
would like to do and you supercharge it
with big tech
and the way they can manipulate us uh
there is a big problem and that's a
perfect segue
uh to the third story which is over the
last couple weeks
you know the trump team has been teasing
out that they were going to do something
on the tech side now you may remember
about two months ago
they released this blog in essence it
was called from the desk of donald trump
or from the desk of the former president
something like that
and really all it was was a blog it was
a place where he was writing a few
sentences
and then there were buttons on it where
it was like send to twitters and to
facebooks and to
pinterest or whatever other things
people are on these days
and it really it had no technological
benefit it wasn't solving any problems
it seemed like a really kind of
short-sighted
thing to do now you know my feelings i i
think trump is a good guy i wish the guy
was still president
but i think he late he put out something
that didn't solve any of the problems
and by the way
that's obviously true and i think he
would even admit it himself because
within a month it was gone well anyway
over the last couple weeks
they've been teasing out that there is
going to be some new stuff there is a
new site by jason miller who's one of
chase
uh trump's main guys uh one of his the
main people in his uh former
administration who
i believe he still works with uh they
released an app called
getter which is basically just a twitter
clone well on day one
it was already hacked into i think about
90 000
people had their information hacked
trust me i know a little something about
creating a tech company it
ain't that easy in any event over the
last few days they've been saying
trump's gonna make a major announcement
on
wednesday related to tech and everyone
thought that meant he was going to
launch a new tech site
frankly that's not what i thought
because i know how hard it is to do this
stuff i know
by creating locals how hard it is to
actually organize information in a way
that's not going to be hacked and i know
how to deal with
the legal issues and the philosophical
issues around speech
and the technological issues and having
like all the right
uh engineers and architects and all of
those things i just know it's tough and
if like if trump's been working on that
for a long time
it seems like it would have leaked to me
anyway the big announcement
is that trump is actually suing the big
tech companies and as i've said all
along guys
you know we're in a war an information
war there's many ways to fight a war i
believe
in competition so i want to invent and
build new products that's what i'm doing
but i think there's legal means that's
what trump trump's doing
i think there's governmental means my
interview with jd vance which part one
just went up this morning and i've
talked to guys
like josh hawley and tucker carlson
about this that there are legal means to
maybe break up these companies
uh david sachs who i had on a few weeks
ago uh he's one of the guys that wants
to break up some some a big tech at
least break up the apple app store
because they have just complete monopoly
power
the point is there's many ways to fight
a war when you're fighting a war you
have ground troops you have
guys in tanks you have an air force and
there's always do it so trump has
decided
he's going the legal route we've got
some quotes here from the national
review
former president trump announced on
wednesday that he will
file class action lawsuits against
facebook twitter google and the
company's chief executive
officers today i'm filing as the lead
class representative a major class
action lawsuit against the big tech
giants
facebook google and twitter and
ceos mark zuckerberg jack dorsey and
sundar pakkai
trump said at a press conference the
suits will be filed in the southern
district of florida the suit will be
backed by the american first
policy institute a non-profit launched
by former
trump administration members to advance
the former president's policies
trump said that the suits will claim
that the companies enact censorship of
the american people
hailing the suits as a beautiful
development for our freedom of speech
trump said we're going to hold big tech
very accountable
that's classic trump right there it's a
beautiful lawsuit and we're going to
hold
big tech very accountable look i don't
have an inherent problem with this i
really don't
as you know i don't like using all of
these legal levers and governmental
levers all of the time
but there is simply no way
that the government when it was founded
that the founders when they
set up the united states government
could have ever imagined
a superstructure that existed above the
government that was so much more
powerful than the government itself
and if we don't do something about these
companies that are manipulating us in
ways we cannot imagine
it's not the ways we can imagine that
i'm worried about i know what we all
know about shadow banning
we all know how they can reorganize
search results we just have no idea what
else they can do
whether they can truly because of the
suggested videos that
youtube shows you when i'm doing this
show could they if they don't like what
i'm saying could they completely push
you another way
if they really like what i'm saying
could they completely push you this way
we just simply don't know now do i want
a government regulator
try to imagine like a dorky khaki parent
light blue shirt wearing government
regulator with his government hat
walking into google and being like uh
guys can i see the algorithms we're
going to make sure
you're treating information fairly it's
like of course that's not going to work
because nobody
that knows anything about real tech
engineering
and algorithms and anything else would
want to work for the government you'd go
build real things right that was always
my issue with andrew yang it was like
you pretend you're such like a techie
and you know how to do all this stuff
and it's like yet you want to be you
want to first be president and then you
want to be mayor
of new york city it's like go build
stuff right so the government could
never hire people that could even get in
there and
and look at that stuff appropriately
which is why i've come to the conclusion
that perhaps you can sue them right you
can sue them because of censorship and
then we can get into
section 230 of the communications act
that they're acting
not as platforms right where information
is treated equally
this is that what their legal protection
is if you're a platform twitter is a
platform youtube's a platform
facebook's a platform that you treat
everything equally
and then it's it's a forum now you still
can't break their terms of service but
all the information
is treated equally that's different than
say
a provider right that's different than
say the daily wire
or the blaze or fox news or msnbc they
are saying we have
certain content and this is our content
and we are legally responsible for it
so that is the distinction that 230
makes and it's just fairly obvious like
if you're if you're following along at
home
if you've got an iphone in your pocket
if you've got any of these apps on your
phone
you know that it's very obvious that if
you if you're within the woke window
you're safe right like you're just good
to go and you can
say all your crazy racist stuff and you
can call everybody else nazis and white
supremacists and you can do it
and you know you're going to get an
extra star and a check on your
on your paper when you hand it in
because they're into your ideas
where if you're non-woke let's say you
know
you're going to be censored you know
that your videos aren't going to be seen
as much or what you post in your feed
isn't going to be seen
and there's all sorts of other things
you know paul joseph watson tweeted out
something this morning it was a
screenshot
showing that there are basically
hundreds he just did a couple of them
but then i did a further search
that there are basically hundreds of
accounts on twitter they're all
anonymous accounts
and they all just copy and paste the
same exact thing and then they tag boris
johnson in essence
what this was about was that it was like
oh the delta variant's getting worse and
there's other
coronavirus things coming and we have to
lock down again and then they all tag
boris johnson well
why is that dangerous well then whoever
runs boris johnson who's the prime
minister of england obviously
whoever runs his twitter account looks
at his mentions and they go my god
5 000 people all said this thing to us
about the the delta variant and it's and
it's trending on twitter
we better consider lockdowns again so we
are being manipulated who is
manipulating us
i don't know do i do i think it's like
purely like
twitter and facebook employees that are
manipulating us i don't know
is china manipulating us is russia
manipulating us
is our own government manipulating us i
don't know but these are the things that
we should be having an honest discussion
about
and there's another side issue on this
which is that if you think about these
big companies one of the other reasons
that i'm okay with some lawsuits
and that hopefully if nothing else again
i don't want the government regulators
in there but you maybe break them up
right so you could take amazon and you
could say
hey aws your server farm that's what
they blew up with parlor
that can't be part of amazon you know
the amazon when you open your app so you
can buy toilet paper like we have to
break up these companies i don't love
the idea but i get why there's something
sensible there there's just too much
collusion you know amazon
can basically if you're a product person
on their marketplace which is an
incredible thing right they've created
this amazing marketplace so that people
can sell products
one of the things there's many stories
about this when amazon sees that a
particular product is doing really well
so meaning somebody starts their own
small business they start selling it on
amazon amazon gets their cut
they're doing everything by the rules
often what amazon is doing right now is
they just figure out a cheaper way to
make it they make that the amazon's
choice
and then they crush those small
businesses so i don't
love using governmental power but if the
american dream and the ability to
compete
and and the very nature of capitalism is
being destroyed by these companies
then perhaps you do have to do something
so whether it's
some lawsuits some breaking up these
companies of these companies
some new technological answers
locals.com like
that's how we will fix this whole
freaking
thing oh let me just tease out one other
thing i heard something very interesting
this morning from a very reliable source
that sometime next week something
amazing
is going to be announced here in
california have i already said too much
that was too much i've said too much
delete this
can we can you go back and do we have a
time machine is there we got the
gigawatts and the whole thing
but i think something very exciting is
going to happen in california next week
that's all i'm saying for now i just
have a feeling people
can you feel me can hear well hold on
this is for the most dedicated listeners
and viewers of the ruben word i'm going
to try to send you something mentally
right now
about what's going to say perhaps be
announced next week in california it's a
very exciting thing
i'm going to try to send it through the
the pipes
i think some of you got it a couple you
got it very impressive
most impressive guys part one of my
interview with jd
vance who is running for senate in ohio
he's also a tech guy uh really
interesting conversation talking about a
sort of new sort of broad tent wide
conservatism
how you can bring along the the blue dog
democrats obviously something that i
care a bit about
uh part one is up right now on the
youtube and the full episode is up
already ad
free at reubenreport.locals.com
i will be in miami this weekend
why i have my reasons what i have to
tell you everything i mean come on
you know i got some stuff to do and uh
and we'll have another show for you
tomorrow so that's it for now uh i'm
doing an in-person interview in the
house in just a little bit it's a big
one
uh but we'll tease that in a day or two
anyway have a great day everybody
see you tomorrow